all right so how do we learn what are
the basics
okay so something i talk about in my
book is an acronym i came up with which
is
sad so s double a d and the idea is like
revision can be very sad it can be kind
of a miserable experience so rather than
it being sad how can you turn it sad
and each of these things stand for a
little hack based off the science of
learning um where i you know i've done
loads of research into different
academic papers and evidence-based
techniques sort of boiled it down to
four things that you can look at every
way that you're revising to question
yourself whether it's actually effective
or not
and i don't know if you want me to run
through what those are yes i guess i've
led a bit of mystery now yes so the
first one is s which is space repetition
so this is the idea of the forgetting
curve of human memory
so um
yeah how we learn is humans we often
like to sit there we like to cram think
we're studying by revising for 10 hour
blocks and then
going away and not reviewing this
information for a very long time but
that's not how human memory works we
start off a hundred percent of whatever
we've learned and then it exponentially
decreases human memory just absolutely
decays over time so you can imagine you
know you've had a class you've had a new
lesson on something in biology and then
two days later you can't even remember a
single thing you've you've just looked
at um and then when you come to revise
it again in a month you're starting
totally from scratch because you don't
even remember what you first learned
so the idea of space repetition is you
can hack human memory by reviewing this
information at regularly increasing
intervals so for example you have that
day in your classroom where you've
learned something new then the day after
you go back and you look at it then
three days after you go back and look at
it five days seven days
and you slowly increase that time and
all of a sudden it's being put into your
long-term memory so that is the first s
is space repetition
and you know that applies to any
technique you're going to use whether
that's flash cards or
even highlighting your notes if you are
going to be repeating it it's going to
go in more a lot a lot better than doing
it once in a blue moon do you know what
that applies to physical skills as well
i wouldn't be surprised if it does but i
don't have a lot of um a lot of
expertise on like muscle memory and that
kind of thing
yeah but i wouldn't be surprised because
i guess it's still a facet of human
learning
interesting all right what's the a
okay so we've got two a's in here we've
got active recall
so this is this actually i think is one
of the most important things that people
should understand
because
so much of how people often revise is
passive it's where you're looking at
information and it makes you feel
intelligent because of course everything
you're looking at is right you know
you're looking at a diagram with
everything already labeled for you and
you're nodding away feeling like you're
putting it in your brain you're flicking
through that textbook you're re
rereading your notes you're spending
hours rereading and it just feels like
you are full of information
but in reality none of that is going in
and it's actually really
counter-intuitive how learning works
it's less about what you're putting in
and breathing into your brain it's more
about what you're testing yourself on
and what you're dragging out and that is
what active recall is
it's sitting down
asking yourself tough questions about
the topic that you're trying to learn
and
trying to find the answers yourself and
if you can't find them you you can then
look at them and then the next day
you're going to ask yourself the
questions again so it's finding revision
techniques which are yeah requiring that
more active element
so that's something like active recall
is something that i never knew was a
thing
when i was it when i was at uni
bonkers
it is bonkers and it's crazy because
you know even the aesthetic of studying
i feel is highlighting you know you have
pastel highlighters and you feel really
good about it
and jade that's just oh maybe that's
just me in the aesthetic like study
tumblr world but
yeah there's something about
highlighting information which makes you
feel like you're doing something
valuable um but when you look into the
science of it it doesn't actually
do that much for you yeah it has to be
repeated recall not repeated exposure
like that's the difference between the
two and you're totally correct as you
look at something
over and over again you become more
familiar with it but familiarity and
recall ability are not the same thing
but they cannot they can kind of like
seem like they're the same thing as you
read a page oh yeah yeah that bit the
paragraph about about
the berlin wall or whatever it is that
you're learning about
you know what's coming up but you don't
know it enough to be able to close the
textbook and do it so what's a
what's a good way for someone to do
active recall just look at it
look at a question close it try and
answer it
so one of my favorite techniques which i
talk about in a different chapter of how
to apply these methods it's called
blurting
and the idea is
it's a horrible name isn't it but
it's memorable
i was going to say i've talked about
this on my youtube channel before and i
think it's the most popular revision
method that's been discussed i have
people even to this day like messaging
me being like jade blarting has changed
my life
all right well that's all done let's
hold on to that let's finish off sad and
then we'll get into
that that word that i really don't want
to say
um
so yeah the other a is associations
which is the idea that whenever you're
learning something new if you can
associate it to something you already
know
the likelihood that you're gonna
remember it and that you're gonna you're
gonna make sense of it is exponentially
higher so i use a non-study example um
just to explain this to people is how i
i'm off able to remember people's names
quite well if you think you know you're
at a party you're going round you're
meeting so many new people and when you
hear someone's name the odds are you've
forgotten about it before they've even
finished saying it
and the way that you can remember names
more easily is if when the second you
hear their name trying to associate it
to something else that you know about
either that name or
the way that person looks or something
about that word an example i give is you
know say someone is called charlotte
that's a that's a standard name very
easy to forget but if in that one or two
seconds you can think about a charlotte
that you know maybe your neighbor's
called charlotte and you're you're
taking one second just to think oh this
person doesn't really look like my
neighbor charlotte or oh i don't know
like just some something some element of
the name that brings up an association
or memory um just means that the next
time you see that person you're bringing
to mind this association that you've
created for yourself and you're more
likely to bring that word that name back
and the way that you can apply this to
studying is say you're learning
something new in a classroom
um when you're learning something if you
can instantly think okay how does this
link to the last class i took how does
this link to a different topic or even a
different subject how does this work for
a test question i've seen and even just
scribbling notes on the side like oh
i've seen something like this before is
really increasing the associations and
the the rate of retention that you'll
have because you're building on
foundations of your
existing knowledge all right d
d desirable difficulty
so this is the idea that we don't really
like to challenge ourselves naturally
you're always going to reach for what
feels easy
and so that means if a subject you're
really good at it you're more likely to
go back and study it than that subject
that you really hate
um so it's constantly questioning does
this feel really easy for me right now
and if it does how can i make it harder
so maybe you're looking at a flash card
set and it's just got quite easy for you
then it's time to move on to test
questions or practice papers or
something that while you're doing it
feels like a challenge and that's how
you know you're you're spending your
time well
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace
you